hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem design twitter
this is a somewhat challenging problem
for a medium and spoiler alert this is
actually really similar to another leak
code problem which is called merge k
sorted lists and that problem is
actually a hard problem so it's kind of
weird that they make this a medium
problem because this problem is actually
even harder than the merge case sorted
list problem but that's okay so we are
told to design a simplified version of
twitter and this problem is really about
which data structures are we going to
use for each of these functions so you
really need to have an understanding of
trade-offs to make sure that we
implement each of these functions in the
most efficient way so there's in total
five functions we wanna do one is the
constructor so that's where we're really
just gonna handle what data structures
we wanna use like initializing them and
all that and i'm actually gonna start
with the implementation for these two
functions the follow function and the
unfollow function
so any user in this case the follower id
is the user can follow another user and
that's called the follow e id followee a
little bit confusing for me but so
clearly with this function we need to
keep track that this user is following
this user right we need a data structure
to do that now there's a bunch that we
could do the easiest one that you might
consider is a map right we want to map
this user to another user
but of course a user
can actually not just follow one person
but they could follow multiple people so
the simplest idea that you might think
of is first okay create a hash map right
uh where we're gonna map the user id
right just some generic user to whoever
they're following right we'll call that
the follow eid but it's not just going
to be one so let's actually call it list
of followee ids right that's just our
naive approach that's just the first
thing that came to our mind so if each
time we get a user and we are told that
they follow somebody else we can just
keep adding that you know user that they
follow to the end of that list that we
have right in our hash map this is going
to be the key this is going to be
the key is going to map to a list and we
can add a new value to that list and of
one time so that's easy but now we're
introducing a second operation called
unfollow so if a user now wants to
unfollow another user how can we
implement it with our current data
structure well removing from a list is
not as easy as adding to the end of that
list because we might actually have to
search through the entire list to even
find that a follower id that we're
trying to remove and then removing it is
going to be a big-o of end time
operation is there a more efficient way
that we can do this well there is a data
structure we know that can add and
remove in o of one time do you know what
it is well hashmap is one of them but in
this case we don't really need a map we
just need a set of values right a list
or a set but in this case we can use a
hash set and that can insert and remove
in big o of one time so instead of using
a list which was our naive approach
we're actually going to map each user id
to a hash set of follow eids okay so
that's actually pretty easy right so
we've already figured out a follow and
we've already figured out unfollow and
of course we're going to be initializing
this data structure inside of our
constructor but now for the somewhat
difficult part the post tweet and the
get news feed function so let's start
with post tweet each user can post a
tweet and obviously they can post more
than one tweet so we need to be able to
map a user to their list of tweets right
let's just start with a list again and
see if it works out for us so again
we're gonna have a hash map okay so
we're gonna have another hash map
mapping each user id to the list of
their tweets and each time we post a
tweet for a given user we're just going
to take that tweet and add it to the end
of that list so let's just see if that
works for now that's like the most naive
approach and in this case i'll just tell
you it is going to work for us and
you're going to see why so by the way
this post tweet if we're just adding to
the end of the list each time we can do
that in big o of one time so we've
basically got all three of these
functions running in big o of one time
but this get news feed is going to be by
far the most complex function so
basically for any given user we want to
retrieve the 10
most recent tweet ids for that user and
the way we're going to get the 10 most
recent tweets is from the list of uh
followees of the list of people that
that user follows right and from that
list of people that they follow we want
the 10 most recent tweets now how do we
even get most recent well one anytime a
user posts a tweet we're already adding
it to the end of the list right so if we
create a list of tweets right let's say
this is the first tweet then we have the
second tweet then we have the third
tweet of course the most recent tweet is
going to be at the end of the list right
for any given user but we don't just
have one user right it's possible that
we were told okay this user uh you know
we're given some user but they maybe
follow two people right maybe the second
person that they follow has these tweets
four five six and let's say these are
the actual tweet ids right so we know
that this is the most recent tweet from
the first person that they follow and
this is the most recent tweet from the
second person that they follow but these
values we can't just compare the tweet
ids right because that's what we have
right now a list of tweet ids so instead
of just having a list of tweet ids how
about we also keep track of the time
that that tweet was posted so in that
case we won't just have a list of tweet
ids we'll have a list of pairs a list of
i'm going to call it count because
that's what we're going to be keeping
track of for time right we don't
actually have a time we have a count of
how many total tweets we have and we're
actually going to start our count at 0
and then we're going to decrement it to
negative 1 then to negative 2 then a
negative three and you're gonna see why
it basically has to do with us using a
heap uh and in python at least there's
not really a max heap so we're gonna be
using a min heap if you're if you're
doing this in java by the way you can
just take the count and start at zero
and then increment it to one then to two
then the three but in this case i'm
going to be decrementing it from one to
negative one to negative two and it'll
work out for us this count isn't the
most important part of this function
okay so once again let's say we're
trying to run get newsfeed for some
particular user now first thing we want
for that user is who do they follow how
can we get that well remember we have a
hash map for that we can take this user
id and get a hash set of all the people
that they follow and a hash set in this
case is basically equivalent to a list
for us because we're just going to
iterate through all the people that they
follow and then get the tweets of those
people right so for each followee id
that's a person right that's a user how
do we get their list of tweets well
conveniently we have a second hash map
for that we can take that uh followee id
and then convert it into a list of their
account and tweets right and that count
is really just going to be used to
figure out what tweet
occurred most recently so suppose we did
all that work right we took some user
and then got a list of all the people
that they follow and their particular
tweets let me just draw some example for
that let's say we have one three five uh
and let's say these are the counts right
because we know that that list is
actually going to have a pair of values
count and tweet id uh we do care about
the tweet id as well because that's what
we're gonna be returning remember we're
returning a list of the tweet ids that
occurred most recently the 10 tweets
that occurred most recently and if there
aren't 10 let's say there's only eight
tweets from all the people that they
follow then we occur however many we
have right we don't go over 10 but if
there's less than 10 then we'll return
however many we have but in this case uh
let's say there are less than 10 let's
say we have two four and then for the
other one let's say we have a six
seven so not only do we want at most ten
tweets but they need to actually be
ordered from most recent to least recent
so how do we do that that's really the
main portion of this algorithm and it's
basically exactly like merge k sorted
lists the naive way to do this would run
in big o of 10
times k where k is basically the number
of people that that user follows and let
me tell you why because of course for
each in this case we have three right
basically i'm saying k is equal to three
because we have three different lists uh
if we're trying to get the most recent
tweets and order them in that way of
course we're gonna start at the end of
each list right so we're gonna have a
pointer for each list you can call it an
index or whatever you want and we're
going to compare all of these right
which one occurred most recently which
one has the smallest value in this case
four is the smallest value so what are
we going to do well we're gonna take 4
and add it to our list i'm kind of
running out of space so let me just
create a variable up here sorry if it's
messy so result is going to be our list
so we found the first value it's 4 so
we're going to add 4 to that list and
then we're going to take that pointer
which was here and then decrement it
we're going to shift it to the left so
now it's going to be over here and then
we're basically going to keep repeating
this right we're going to take the
minimum of all of these and the reason
the time complexity is 10 times k is
obviously we have k lists to find the
minimum between k values it's a big o of
k operation so that's the naive way to
do it but if you've solved merge k
sorted lists before you know that we
don't have to do it in the naive way the
slightly more optimal way to do this is
actually to take our frontier of all
these lists basically frontiers all of
the pointers right wherever the pointers
are take this this and this and add it
to a data structure called the heap in
our case we want the min heap because we
want the minimum value right we want to
know which one of these occurred most uh
recently uh and actually that reminds me
we remember we were actually going to
make these values negative so sorry if
this was confusing or remember we were
going to start at 0 and then make all
these negatives so
that doesn't really change the problem
at all but it's just how we're going to
implement it in the code if you're using
java by the way you don't need to make
them negative because java has a max
heap which you can use but we will be
using a min heap and python but the idea
is the same right we're going to take
these values add them to a heap in our
case we're going to be using a min heap
and then from this value this value and
this value we're going to find the
minimum we're going to do that in log k
time
and how many times are we going to do
that log k operation well of course only
at most 10 times right so the time
complexity is 10 times log k so that's
better than 10 times k which we
previously had right well not quite
actually
and that's kind of the dumb part about
this
even if you do use them in heap it
doesn't really change the overall time
complexity let me tell you why because
let's say we take each of these k values
and we add them to the heap we can add
these values in two different ways we
can push each of these values which
would result in k times log k just to
push these values these k values to the
min heap or we could run heapify which
would be a big o of k time operation so
that in addition to our 10 times log k
it makes the overall time complexity
still big o of k which is what we
already originally had so it actually
doesn't change the overall time
complexity uh but the benefit is if you
know if we were running this algorithm
in a generic case where we didn't have
to actually receive uh 10 uh different
tweets maybe we had to receive
up to n tweets our algorithm using a
heap would be more efficient so i think
i've talked enough about the complexity
and how we're actually gonna design this
now it's actually time to implement the
solution and code it up just to save a
bit of time i'm just gonna copy and
paste a few lines of code so remember
we're gonna have three main variables in
our constructor we're gonna keep track
of the count initially it's gonna be
zero uh we're gonna use the count to
basically uh it would be better to call
this time but it really is just counting
our number of tweets so basically we can
maintain which tweet was created earlier
than another tweet we're also gonna have
a tweet map where we map each user to a
list of uh that user's tweets as well as
the count which is uh gonna be used to
figure out which tweet was created uh
earlier and of course we want to be able
to have a follow map to
maintain a user and a set of all the
people that they follow so i'm actually
going to implement the follow and
unfollow first because they're a lot
easier so for follow we take our follow
map and
for a follower id we want to say okay
this uh person is now following another
person uh with the uh followee id so
with the hash set we're gonna add to
that hash set this followee id so that's
pretty easy now in the unfollow it's
basically the reverse of this right a
user is now unfollowing someone so
instead of adding we're gonna remove but
what if this person is actually not even
following a different person well let's
just add a conditional to make sure that
they are following before we actually
call the remove function because at
least in python i think it will throw
like an exception or something so let's
just
make sure if follow e id is in
the set for that follower id so if that
is the case only then are we actually
going to remove it okay so that was the
easy part now let's do post tweet it's
the second easiest so for any user uh
they just created a tweet so we want to
be able to record that so in our tweet
map we're gonna say oh and by the way i
didn't mention we're using default dicks
in this case default dictionaries or
hash maps in this case of course we have
a list right that's going to be what
we're recording and in this one we have
a set main reason i'm doing it like this
is just to save a couple lines of code
if we didn't have default dicks we could
have just initialized it to a regular
hashmap but in that case each time i'm
adding values like see here i'm adding
values i would have to initialize it
before so i'd have to say
follower id
is going to equal a list and or in this
case a set and then i can add it right
first we'd have to create an empty set
and then add the
values to that set doing it this way
just saves a few lines of code i think
in most cases your interviewer would
probably be fine with it but if they're
not you can always just write it out
it's pretty easy to do it just saves us
a few lines of code in this case so in
the tweet map for this user id we want
to append to the end of the list the
tweet id but actually not just the tweet
id remember because we determined that
we need to record a pair of values we
need to record the count uh that this
tweet was created at so that we know
which tweet was created before another
tweet
actually i think we're trying to figure
out which tweet was created most
recently uh but either way our account
will help us for that and then after
we've done that we want the next tweet
to be uh created at a different count so
we're gonna actually decrement this so
that we can use this in our min heap in
our this function that's i think pretty
much it for post tweet so now basically
to the main part of this algorithm to
get news feed so like i said we're gonna
have a result right that's gonna be the
list of tweets so it's gonna be ordered
starting from the most recent tweets uh
for all the people that this person
follows and we're also going to be
needing a min heap to figure out what
the most recent were so initially the
min heap is going to be empty we are now
going to go through
every person that this user follows how
can we get that how can we get the
followee id of each person that this
user follows well remember we have a
follower map for that so follower map
don't forget to use self in python
for this user id so we want to go
through each followee id and what do we
want to do with that followee id we want
the most recent tweet that this person
created right our frontier basically
first we're going to get the index and
that index is basically just going to be
the last value of the list so first to
even get the list we need the tweet map
of this followe id so this will give us
a list we want the length of this list
minus 1 because that will give us the
last index and using that last index we
can take that list
so this is the list we're going to index
it so basically look at this position of
the list which will give us the last
value and remember this itself is a pair
of values the count and the tweet id so
count tweet id and this is what's going
to be added to our min heap so i'm
initially just going to append this to
the min heap we don't need to heap push
it or anything and then we can heapify
this after we've added every value that
we want to it so i'm appending to the
min heap the first value so it's going
to be not just a pair of values but it's
actually going to be 4 values and you're
going to see why but the first value is
what's used as the key as long as
there's not a tie and there won't be a
tie in this case because count is always
going to be unique for every single
tweet in this case i'm gonna add that
count as the first value because that's
what we want to use as the key that's
what we want to order our min heap and
then the remaining i'm gonna of course
need to add the tweet id because that's
we're gonna we're gonna end up adding to
the result and i'm also going to be
adding the followee id of this person
because after we pop this tweet we also
want to get the next tweet from this
followee id right so we using this
followee id we're going to go back to
the list and then get the next position
at the next index not really the next
index but the previous index so really
i'm going to decrement this index by one
so let's make sure to store that index
also in our min heap just so we have it
so we can take that index decrement it
by one but we're basically saying that
this is the next position we're going to
look at in our list over here as long as
it's greater than or equal to zero
basically as long as there are still
elements in that list for that followee
id okay that's definitely a lot going on
here which is why this problem is pretty
difficult for a medium and actually one
thing i forgot to do is
we're not 100 sure that this followee id
this person even has any tweets that
they created so before we even try to uh
you know look at it inside of the tree
map before we try to look at some index
let's make sure that at least has one
tweet so basically if followee id is in
self.tweet map if that is the case then
they have at least one tweet so that's
when we're gonna be actually running
this portion okay so we go through every
uh person that they follow after we do
that let's make sure to actually turn
this list because right now it's just a
list we want to turn it into a heap a
min heap so in python we can do that
like this heapq.heapify
to that key okay now we actually get
into the main portion of the algorithm
remember we want to pop
at most 10 values we can run a while
loop basically saying while the min heap
is non-empty and the result or or the
length of the result is less than 10. so
basically if we run out of values this
is going to stop even if we don't have
10 but right if our min heap is empty
it'll stop if we reach 10 values it'll
also stop each time though we're going
to pop from the min heap we want the
most recent tweet that occurred we can
do that in python like this heap q dot
heap pop from the min heap it's going to
pop four values that we defined up here
right so i'm just gonna copy and paste
that
four values we don't need the minus one
so
these are the values it's gonna give us
and of course we want the tweet id
that's the most important because that's
what we're going to end up adding to the
result this is the most recent tweet
that happened so we can go ahead and add
it to the result now if this followee id
this person had any more tweets we want
to get that tweet and we can get it at
this index let me just actually copy and
paste this because we're using the same
variable names which makes it convenient
for us so let me uh so from the tweet
map we're going to get that person and
this index which will tell us the next
tweet that we can add to our min heap
this remember returns a pair of values
which we defined up here count and tweet
id so let's re-define count and redefine
tweet id which we you know used up here
that's okay we'll redefine them because
this is these two values are what we're
now going to be uh pushing to the heap
we can do that like this heap q dot heap
push to the min heap and we're always
adding four values to it the first one
is going to be the count next is going
to be the tweet id next is going to be
the followee id which we have up above
and last is going to be the index but
remember we always add the index minus 1
because we're adding the next index uh
but don't forget we just ran these two
lines of code right but we're assuming
that the index is going to be valid
we're assuming that the index is going
to be greater than or equal to zero that
that person has some more tweets left
that we haven't already added to the min
heap so let's make sure to have that
conditional up above okay and quite a
bit of code but luckily that is all of
it so after all that is done we have 10
tweets we can go ahead and return the
result and of course i do i miss the
name so this is follower map but we
don't need the er okay and i had one
last bug and actually had to do with how
we read the problem they actually define
the news feed like a user is actually
technically following themself basically
we want the 10 most recent posts from
the people that they follow including
themself so before we even run this
function what we're actually going to do
is to the follow map of that person
we're just going to add themselves to it
i think that's one of the easiest ways
to do this so for that user user id
we're going to add themselves to it so i
think that's kind of dumb if i was doing
this in a real interview i think i'd
probably miss this detail but it's just
one thing you need to do to pass this
problem so now let's run it i really
hope i don't have any more bugs and
luckily it actually does work so you can
see on the left yes it works and it's
pretty efficient so i really hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it really supports the
channel a lot consider checking out my
patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching